So we said we're going to
focus on what we do online.
So let's dig deeper into it.
What that we do online should
be considered private?
Okay, so what is private?
And I think we're really talking
about either data that is going to be
stored in digital form in computers,
or some activity that we do and
record of that activity is
what we're talking about.
So financial statements,
we do online banking,
credit card statements,
all these financial records,
we would say, that should be private,
for two reasons.
It's no one's business how I spend my
money or how much of it I have, but
if they gain access to these,
of course, they can do identity theft.
Health medical conditions,
health information is obviously
highly sensitive and
we don't want that to be made public.
Legal matters they're attorney client
privileges, and things like that.
Well, most people would view that as
something that is private information.
If it's online in email messages or
certain files that are stored in
a computer, of course, you would
view them as private information.
Biometrics, fingerprints for
example, which could be used for
gaining access to certain information.
You would think your fingerprints
shouldn't be arbitrarily collected,
shared, be made public and
things like that.
So you would say this
is private as well.
Your political beliefs,
what party you belong to.
Well, you can always find out from
what button someone's wearing or
what party they contribute to but
it's no one's business if I
don't want to make it public.
Remember, it's your ability to control,
and
when you making a contribution or when
you are putting a button of supports
on a certain candidate, to do that.
So the ability to control is
what is privacy is all about.
So my political belief,
unless I want to disclose it,
there's no reason why someone
should find out about it.
Although we didn't talk about
privacy related laws, but
in the US there are laws
that cover some of these.
Health, for example, HIPAA.
Financial, there is Sarbanes-Oxley and
things like that.
So, the privacy laws, not only this
information is private, considered
private, but those who thwarted privacy,
there could be sanctions against them.
Well, if we go on school records,
your employment record is private.
Most of us would want to
keep our annual evaluations,
won't want them out in the public.
School records, how you do your
grades are actually covered again
as regulation, and things like that.
And more interestingly,
our web browsing habits.
What do we search?
What websites do we visit?
What kind of websites?
If somebody knew, then maybe they'd know
your political beliefs, for example.
So what we do online,
you would think that's private.
Communication that's not public.
Emails that you send or
phone calls that you make and so
on, you would think that is private.
Our [INAUDIBLE] and we've been talking a
lot about metadata and stuff like that.
And a lot of people are upset and
surprised and some maybe not because
we did think phone calls,
we had control in a sense that
we knew that the government wouldn't
collect information about those.
So communication is certainly a thing
that you would consider private.
And if you sort of keep going down
this line, what we do in cyberspace,
what about stuff that's about us
that can be seen by others online.
Going back to whenever.
What about past history?
So the interesting are the right to be
forgotten this thing in the EU now that
we have, and
we'll explore it a bit more.
It says if there's information about me
that's irrelevant I don't want Google
to actually return that as a result
of a search that somebody performs.
So if there's information out there
that was collected and made public or
made available to somebody,
is that forever or do I have
the right to remove it at some point.